[Music]
basic targeting with the Joe so this is
a small series talking about Joe work
where we're not going to talk about a
lot of the stuff that's often really
popularized so if you look on YouTube
right now there's tons of videos on the
cebu T or the Kumi Joe or different
aspects of Aikido weapons work but
there's not a lot of people talking
about how you actually hit something
with the Joe and if you can't hit
something with this weapon then all the
training you're doing is useless so you
have to be able to hit this I recommend
lots of different kinds of targets these
are just some simple ideas to get you
started so I'm this one we're working
with a partner who's got another Joe so
my partner's gonna hold the Joe out in a
slightly long Kin Kin c'mon so he went
regula regular ken come on he's really
got to come out long so this way there's
no chance of me hitting hammers hands or
anything else I'm gonna practice my
gaiden guys so in the you wanna weapons
work this abuti is ski gay Don yeah
right now we're just gonna focus on the
getting guy so I'm gonna go ahead and
pull it into the low position here and
I'm gonna strike to make it get in guy
so when I'm doing this I want to focus
on my hips turning to make power when I
do that the power for the getting guys
comes in the the legs pushing against
the ground and making hips move and
that's what's gonna make the the Joe
begin to move really fast if I focus too
much on my arms or too much on my feet
then I won't get a really nice kit right
I'll get dumb hits that kind of look
like this okay that's my arms or if I go
like this my legs so instead I want to
put the power in my hips by driving from
Mike my legs and coming through okay so
you get a really big shot that way so
when I'm here I have it set up I turned
my hips this is a pretty safe practice I
have yet to break a Joe doing this exact
practice although we for warned is you
put more and more power into the weapons
they will crack you're gonna get broken
weapons if you've never broken a weapon
before it's publix you're not hitting
stuff a lot these things are not you
know invincible they will break so so be
forewarned that's coming all right now
that's the basic practice I'm gonna give
you a little warning about that so as
you start learning how to do this you
start turning your hips you're gonna
start cheating the practice I mean what
you're gonna do is you're going to start
setting it tight to your hips and you're
gonna start doing which is basically the
right action but you're gonna do it
because he's set up there and he's not
moving around and I can hit him
amazingly hard because I can set that
shot up really really well so once you
can hit it powerfully you need to then
be able to hit powerfully on the fly
because remember if you're fighting
someone with this weapon
they're not gonna be standing still
waiting all day for you to get the
perfect position so you have to be able
to set up in a way that immediately
after one move I can go into the net so
now we're gonna use the ski getting guys
for this maybe step back just a tad bit
that's perfect good case on here I'm
gonna ski then immediately after my gosh
and so those should be able to be done
powerfully together see ya okay if I
cannot do it with another action then
it's pretty much useless to me cuz
that's what's gonna be happening I'm
gonna be trying to do one thing he's
moving or change I'm gonna fall through
with another action so here we're gonna
use the ski getting guys ski now notice
I'm going all forward on that I'm not
going back going back for the getting
guy is just something to keep you in a
straight line you don't need to do that
in fact most the time when you're using
it getting guys you're gonna be going
forward so go forward with your ski set
if you're getting guys that's basic
getting guys practice